la primera ministra de perú violeta
bermúdez anunció que el gobierno de
francisco sagasti no descansará hasta
que se conozca toda la verdad sobre la
aplicación irregular de la vacuna
destino farm previamente ante dos
comisiones de investigación del congreso
de perú germán málaga jefe de los
ensayos clínicos reveló que el ex
presidente de martín vizcarra le
solicitó dosis de las vacunas para él su
esposa y su hermano málaga dijo que
vizcarra fue informado de que los
medicamentos no pertenecían al ensayo
clínico y sobre los más de 400
funcionarios inmunizados señaló que
siguieron indicaciones de un oficial de
enlace y no preguntaron nombres el
parlamento debate la organización de una
comisión multisectorial que se espera
lleve el caso mientras tanto se han
lanzado cuatro denuncias
constitucionales contra martín vizcarra
por presuntos ilícitos contra la
administración pública y corrupción de
funcionarios algunos parlamentarios
buscarían inhabilitar a vizcarra por 10
años de toda función pública antes de
que se realicen las elecciones del 11 de
abril donde el ex presidente pretende
postular al congreso mientras tanto la
fiscalía está interviniendo las
instalaciones de la universidad cayetano
centro de los ensayos clínicos para
recabar toda la información sobre los
altos funcionarios del estado vacunados
contra el kobe 19 este escándalo ha
motivado que amnistía internacional
exhorte a las autoridades peruanas a
transparentar los acuerdos con las
farmacéuticas que producen las vacunas